only on CBS This Morning part two of our
investigation into the alleged lack of
diversity at the nation's Premier law
enforcement agency now yesterday you
heard from a group of black former FBI
agents calling for change did you know
that only 4% of FBI agents worldwide are
black this morning two former agents who
fought during their careers to level the
playing field for their fellow black
agents are speaking out after a summer
of racial Reckoning in this country they
say the lack of diversity at the FBA at
the FBI rather has now reached crisis
levels they spoke exclusively to our
Jeff gaze Jeff good morning to
you good morning Gail FBI officials say
that they are dedicated to diversity
that it is a core value but the former
black agents we spoke with say that they
experienced and witnessed something
entirely different during their decades
long careers inside the
FBI when the culture is not conducive to
minorities you have an obligation to
speak out Eric Jackson was the special
agent in charge of the FBI's Dallas
field office I believe a crisis is
happening the seventh floor in the FBI
is where decisions and policies are made
right now there are no African-Americans
on the seventh floor of the top 10
leadership positions in the FBI all are
held by white men what has occurred is
what uh a lot of psychologists call
institutionalized racism as head of the
FBI's black Affairs diversity committee
Jackson says he got a firsthand look at
how the upper ranks of FBI leadership
kept blacks from climbing the ladder as
the only black sitting in the room and I
hear people talking about we want to
prevent loing standards we don't want to
change the culture that's code word for
me that we don't believe that there's a
problem you think that's code words oh
absolutely when you leave out of the
room you're demoralized several former
black agents told CBS news that managers
inside the FBI who are mostly white tend
to only promote individuals who look
like themselves first of all the numbers
are horrific black women make up only 1%
of the 13,000 FBI agents around the
world Jennifer Love retired in 2012 as
an assistant director reaching the
highest rank of any black woman in the
FBI's history it became tiring I would
go in and everybody looked the same
white men with their dark suits on their
white shirts their blue and red ties
love says that she was a champion for
the FBI even appearing in recruiting ads
near the end of her career as the
bureau's head of security she oversaw
the mandatory polygraph examinations for
new recruits I had a stack of letters
from black and brown people who had
failed the polygraph who said they
thought that they were being asked
inappropriate questions she crunched the
numbers and discovered black applicants
were disproportionately failing the
polygraph exam her proposal videotaped
the polygraphs to create accountability
I can tell you internal to my division
they were opposed to it they they didn't
want to do it they didn't want to do it
the number of black agents in the FBI
has hovered so low for so long that they
have created this they call it a buffalo
nickel it is a challenge coin to
commemorate the fact that black agents
historically have only made up about 5%
of the FBI a number that is lower today
to sit here today and hear that the
numbers have gotten gotten worse and the
personal sacrifice listen I moved my
kids eight
times two divorces okay I can love the
bureau and want it to be accountable but
you got to believe that it's necessary
this inv Eric Jackson's successful
career came to an abrupt end last year I
saw the glass ceiling he was gunning for
an executive assistant director position
there are only six in the entire FBI he
was told he wasn't eligible because of
his rank Jackson says the bureau changed
the eligibility rules while he was
applying and the job went to a white
agent with similar credentials other
black special agents in charge we we
noticed that and and the message was
sent loud and clear that the the rules
didn't apply to us Jackson retired last
year after 21 years with the FBI how are
you going to respond to people who just
say this is sour grapes if they think
this is sour grapes then they don't
understand uh what's going on because if
if we don't look like the community we
serve how can that Community Trust
us all of the former agents that we
spoke with say they are coming forward
because they love the FBI in the
meantime FBI officials say that director
Ray has expressed a willingness to uh
discuss some of the issues raised by our
report while they regret that he was not
able to schedule an interview before the
report aired officials tell me that
director Ray has expressed a willingness
to sit down for an interview to discuss
some of these issues in the coming weeks
Gil well let me tell you Jeff that is
very encouraging to hear because I'm
thinking there needs to be some meetings
on the seventh floor it's heartbreaking
to hear how these agents have operated
uh dedicated to the FBI agency and to be
treated this way seems like there are a
lot of questions that need to be
answered well there are and I have to
say Gail since our first report aired
we've gotten a lot of emails from other
former black agents and some phone calls
as well all right to be continued Jeff
pay's really nice job